الوقت هو السلطه التي يخضع لها الانسان
حتى لو كان في عنان السماء داخل مركبه
فضائيه معظم الناس تهتم بالمال اكثر من
الوقت ولا يدركون ان الاخير اكبر قيمه
واهميه من الذهب النفيس فب الوقت يمكن
تقديس الاموال بينما كل ما للدنيا لا يعطي
الحق بشراء ثنيه واحده من الوقت العالم
محكوم بيوم مكون من 24 ساعه فقط لكن كيف
اذا اصبح عدد الساعات اليوم 30 ساعه بدلا
من اربع وعشرين فكره تدعو للدهشه بعد
الشيء خاصه ان المراه معتدل على نظام حياه
محدد لكن مسيره تطور السريع في بعض بلدان
العالم تتطلب تقسيمه وقت العمل والراحه
على عدد اكبر من الساعات وهذا ما يعتبره
البعض خطوه اكثر فائده خاصه انا فكره
تقديم وتاخير الساعه ما بين الشتاء والصيف
لكسب الوقت لم تعد تربي طموحه حتى تمور
ياتي يومنا المكون من 24 ساعه من قدماء
المصريين الذين قسموا وقت النهار الى عشر
ساعات قاموا بقياسها بساعات الظل وتم
تقسيم الليل الى 12 ساعه بناءا على
ملاحظات النجوم وكان طول ساعات النهار
والليل غير متساوي ومتنوع باختلاف الفصول
وفي عصر الدوله الحديثه تم تبسيط النظام
باستخدام مجموعه من اربع وعشرين النجمه 12
من هذه النجمه تمثل مرور فتره الليل
والباقي مثل مرور النهار اما التقسيم
الفرعي للساعات والدقائق الى 60 ياتي من
البابلي القدماء الذين وضعوا دائره
وقسموها الى 360 جزءا واختاروا هذا الرقم
نسبه لعدد ايام السنه وتم اتباع النظام
السداسي لتقسيم الوقت لتسهيل عمليه تغسيل
الدائره الاربعه وانصاف كانت هناك محاولات
بعد ثوره الفرنسيه لتقسيم الوقت بطريقه
مختلفه وتطبيق نظام عشري يقسم عدد دقائق
والثاني الى مئه وحده بدل من 60 وحده لكن
لي سهل ان تقنع العالم كله بتغيير نظام
فما تبنيه منذ قرون بالاضافه الى
التعقيدات الاقتصاديه والتكنولوجيه التي
قد يواجهها امر كهذا
[موسيقى]
الاستوديو ينضم الينا مصمم الساعات جهاد
بكوره جهاد يسعد صباحك اهلا بك طيب احنا
نظامنا متعودين عليهم بعايشين به 24 ساعه
انتم جائتكم فكره 30 ساعه صممتم ساعه ب 30
ساعه حدثنا عن الفكره اولا وشو الحكمه
منها
واكيد الوقت مهم جدا مع الانسان وبيعيش
معه وبيموت
فالوقت اليوم
موجوده على الرجل الكره الارضيه والتغيرات
والسرعه هذا الموضوع
لكن الانسان يعني اليوم انت عندك باليوم
اقل شيء في عندك هدرس ست ساعات اليوم هو
ساعه العمل الاكاديميه 45 دقيقه
هي 50 دقيقه اليوم عم نفكر كيف نحن نرجع
لك الزمن اللي انت متضاي اليوم مشان تقدري
تواكبي السرعه والتطورات
كمان بيكون احسن واحسن طيب جهاد هل حصل
معك اي ظرف في حياتك استدعاك انك تروح
تصمم هيك ساعه
فكرنا كيف احنا ممكن
التطورات والسرعه تحت اطار الوقت الموجود
والتقسيم الموجود يا اما نكبر التقسيم
الموجود لحتى يقدر الانسان او التطورات
الموجوده الوقت
فكرنا بموضوع هذا الشيء واجهت الفكره من
الصراحه يعني من همم مشروع 20 30
هنقول لك انه انت اليوم عندك 30 ساعه ما
عندك 24 هن نفسهم يعني احنا نغير اليوم
اليوم
24 ساعه ساعه
في عملك خاصه في صح يعني مثلا بس هي
بتتقسم على عمله مثلا خارجيه مثلا مثل
جرينتش الوقت والوقت اللوكل اللي عندك
موجود
تقريبا حساباتها مختفيه بس انت بتعرفي
باليوم قديش عندك وقت بالضبط راحه يعني
مثلا الموظف اليوم بشتغل 10 ساعات في عنده
اكيد تسويه كثير لانه بتعرفي انت انه هو
ساعه العمل تبعه الحقيقيه 50 دقيقه اذا
بقول له بتاخدهم باخر النهار ساعتين وتروح
على بيتك احسن له طيب جهاد مين تتوقع انه
هيكون الفئه اللي راح تقبل عشره هاي
الساعه محبين الموضه والازياء انه انا
لابسه ساعه 30 ساعه الا رجال الاعمال
هلا اكيد هاي الفكره موجوده كانت من قبل
كمان لانه هو بايام الحضارات القديمه على
وقتها
من اليوم
من الشرقيه
اكتبي بما انه عجبتكم معناته راح تمشي
يعني التصميم الاول طلع وحائط تخرج الساعه
الى العالم ب 20 30 ماشيه تنفيذ الرؤيه
هذا الموضوع فعلا هي نحنا بنعطيك بس احساس
زياده بالوقت يعني الوقت هو مد وجزر على
حسب ما انت بتفكري فيه بطول او بين ناقصه
اذا قاعده مع شخص بتحبيه
واذا قاعده مع شخص بفكره هي دقيقه ساعه
وبعدين نحن عم نرجع لك الاحساس دائما انه
انت عندك في وقت اهدر في عندك قصص ممكن
انت تستفادي منها
راح ما البس هذه الساعه وهيكون نهارك انا
بخفف لك حدد الثوانيات خليك فيها تمشي على
مهلك شوي او تسرع اكثر وانت بتحسي في صراع
اكثر احساس الوقت احساس طبعا
هل نتوقع ان تكون متاحه للجميع سعرها متاح
للجميع
بس هو اي واحد بيهمه وقته اكيد راح يقدر
والفكره هي كمان في عندك الوقت انا بعتبر
الوقت
يحط لك يعني اليسار اليمين وهو في التزايد
يعني واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه بس كان بدك
اياه بس اليوم كمان بنفس الساعه احنا
عاملين حمام بلدي من اليمين لليسار تنقص
منك 12 ساعه 11 10 بس من شان انت على فكره